now here's the thing so it is shrouded
in secrecy the whole thing we're not
allowed to do anything so Daisy how long
did you have to keep the secret of
actually being in it that you've got the
part three months no three months you
have to tell someone in three months did
you not know that oh I told them when I
got cast I told the taxi driver I
released it the other day I did tell the
taxi driver I can't lie to you I did
know my family didn't know the taxi
driver did go in the taxi no just like
me I've just been cast in Star Wars he
was just like all right mate so did you
tell first Daisy I told my sister and my
mom when I came in and then I told my
dad and then he was kind of sleeping he
went Jesus Christ then the next day he
was like I think your mom told me
something and I was like no no no I told
you that and then he went oh I was
always more of a trek fan yes yeah
that's a bad father
maybe he's great he's backstage yeah how
was your family when you heard John um
they had no clue what Star Wars was but
they were great that I got a job
okay and carry the secrecy thing how
have you managed to keep I mean did they
give you a script do they give you a
script they gave me a script for about
three hours and waited on you know out
yeah by the gate and so it was a lot of
pressure to I just looked for my bets no
idea what context it was there's nothing
and I still don't know so you know I
don't know it was awful but I told him
no no I know I kept the secret so she is
so rubbish she told me because I knew I
did the show one day it would help me
yeah I know I I was do people do that
people to talk about Sauron I think I
know what happened stick yes have you
seen the film yes but before that a year
ago she told me yeah everything
I can't believe all the people to trust
with the secret I'm not the one
comments you know oh yeah whatever blood
one of the blah blah blah
get down to this one mr. David Beckham
that's my jumper I just wanted to meet
you make